- And researcher Randi's with UC Davis
and Director of the Fragile X
Research and Treatment Center
of the MIND Institute.
She knocks our audience off their feet
every time she speaks.
(Randi groans)
And we are so happy to have you back.
- Oh, thank you.
- I'm not gonna list
all your accomplishments and things.
- Good.
- You're gonna talk about
fragile X, I take it.
- Yeah, new treatments.
- New treatments.
- And then stay afterwards
because we're gonna get
the afternoon speakers together
to talk about what's next.
- Okay, wow, that's exciting.
- That's your pointer.
- Okay, my pointer and my advancer, okay.
So you guys all know
about the MIND Institute,
and we love it.
So my disclosures are,
I'm carrying out a number
of treatment trials, we just got funded
to do the Zynerba trial about CBD,
so I'll talk a little bit about that.
Our metformin study, which
is a new targeted treatment
for fragile X, and perhaps
other forms of autism,
is funded by the Azrieli Foundation.
AFQ056 is an mGluR5 antagonist
and we're funded by NIH.
But AFQ056 is made by Novartis
and we have a fragile X
LEARN study with that combined with using
parent implemented, the
language intervention or PILI
developed by Len Abbeduto at the MIND.
I'm also funded by Ovid
to do a gaboxadol study.
This is a new GABA agonist for individuals
with fragile X.
And I've consulted with
Zynerba to help them develop
their protocol for the
fragile X treatment trials.
So enough for disclosure.
My overview is to really talk
about the latest treatments
for both fragile X syndrome and for autism
and a future look at
treatments for both disorders.
Learning objectives,
understand the relationship
between fragile X and
autism spectrum disorders.
Name a couple medications
for new treatments
for fragile X, the same with autism
and to understand the
difference in fragile X
between the pre mutation
and fragile X syndrome.
I have, I follow a lot
of individuals that have
pre mutation disorders
like FXTAS, tremor ataxia
or fragile X associated tremor ataxia
and I have so many neurologists that see
an older guy with a tremor ataxia syndrome
associated with the pre mutation
and the neurologists say, you don't look
like you have fragile
X syndrome, you know,
you're a smart lawyer and blah, blah blah.
And so a lot of people don't
understand the difference
between pre mutation disorders
and full mutation disorders in fragile X
and it's really fragile X syndrome,
those with the full mutation
or more than 200 repeats
that'll I'll talk about related
to these targeted treatments today.
So this is a new age
of targeted treatments.
It's been going on for the last decade
and we're very excited about that.
Actually things are moving
into stem cell studies,
being able to correct the genetic defect
in stem cells and then
insert it into patients.
It's a very excited new
age, stem cell therapy
and gene manipulation therapy.
So we're gonna have a
conference next year,
probably a year and a half from now
at the MIND Institute
about stem cell therapy
for neurodevelopmental disorders.
You hear a lot about stem cell therapy
for neurodegenerative
disorders, but not so much
about neurodevelopmental.
And there's so many bogus places out there
that are injecting stem cells for autism
and it's just bull.
And you need to be able to sort out
what's real, what's
happening in the research
for many genetic disorders.
It's pretty exciting in the animal models
and I think in a few years it'll move
more into humans.
So but before that takes
place, we are really focused
on targeted treatments that could reverse
some of the neurobiolgical
abnormalities related
to different genetic disorders.
And there's a lot of 'em
going on in fragile X syndrome
and I'll touch on each one of these.
But also it's not just fragile X syndrome.
Angelman syndrome,
gaboxadol has some nice data
for Angelman syndrome and
minocycline was somewhat helpful.
But for Prader-Willi, you get
diagnosed in the first year,
you get put on growth hormone.
I mean, this makes a real difference
for that disorder.
And tuberous sclerosis of
course, various mTOR inhibitors
including rapamycin.
And even Rett syndrome,
there's this paper coming out,
I wrote an editorial for Neurology
because the trofinetide
treatments for Rett syndrome,
this is the IGF1 analog,
there's a real nice study
that's gonna come out in
Neurology I think next month
about trofinetide
treatment in Rett syndrome.
And anavex is a new treatment
that looks really good
in the Rett syndrome animal model.
So these are new targeted treatments
for many more disorders that
you'll hear much more about
and some of these treatments are available
like for instance the
metformin that I'll talk about.
But it's also important to
think about the similarities
across disorders.
Like autism and fragile X both
have real significant GABA
glutamate imbalances and many disorders
with the GABA deficits
will do well I think
with medications that really
enhance GABA pathways,
these inhibitory pathways, and I think
that can help with behavior.
I think just about every
disorder that we look at
has mitochondrial dysfunction
associated with it.
You're not having a mitochondrial mutation
in the mitochondrial
DNA but the mitochondria
don't work as well.
It's very dysfunctional
and so people are doing
more mitochondrial
studies and thinking about
medications that can improve
mitochondrial abnormalities
that impact the development of the child.
Of course all the aging
syndromes, when we talk
about Alzheimer's, or Parkinson's disease
or whatever, all the
neurodegenerative disorders,
they all have mitochondrial abnormalities
and actually everybody gets
more mitochondrial dysfunction
with aging.
If you're older, you really
feel weak in your extremities
sometimes and these are all related
to mitochondrial changes
that occur with aging.
So oxidative stress,
reactive oxygen species
and things that are dramatic antioxidants
that can turn on the
internal antioxidant system
in cells I think can
really make a difference
and we'll maybe talk
about that at the end.
Environmental toxicity
impacts many neurodegenerative
or neurodevelopmental disorder and also
many neurodegenerative disorders.
We study that in FXTAS
and are very worried
about general anesthesia
and the isofluranes
that cause more neuronal cell death.
But we don't worry about it as much
in neurodevelopmental
syndromes, although I think
it does have a big impact in autism
and many other disorders.
I'll talk a little bit
about the fragile X protein
and how this can be a problem
for many other disorders
besides fragile X syndrome.
And when you think about autism and people
have talked about the
heterogeneity and all
of the comorbidities, and this has been
such a great conference, and
I'm sure you've heard a lot
over the last couple days
and many of the things
that we use to treat
autism is maybe focused
on the mood instability
or the ADHD or the anxiety
and we don't really
have something that gets
at the core deficits of autism with social
and communication and these
repetitive behavior problems.
And of course these are just a short list
of all the different disorders associated
with autism and fragile X
is either the most common
or the second most common
cause of genetic disorders
associated with autism.
So whenever you see in autism patients,
this is just to remind
you about the workup.
I'm sure you heard from
Cindy Curry not only
about fragile X DNA testing but CGH array
and battery, you can
look out for ASD genes
and then so much more
whole exome sequencing
and whole genome sequencing.
And you know the genetics
people at UC Davis
are just cranking on the
whole genome sequencing
and finding so many interesting mutations.
We had an interesting
adult not too long ago
that turned out to have
a mutation in a gene
that causes iron deposition in the brain
and you could see it on his MRI
and it was a BPAP mutation.
And this is the only cause of autism
that I think benefits from chelation.
And in fact we put him on despiropone
and he has gotten better as the iron
has gotten out of his brain.
But this is a specific
mutation that causes
iron deposition and in adulthood.
And in his 20s he started developing more
Parkinsonian features
and really deteriorating.
And so he got better.
But that was found through
whole genome sequencing.
So I just wanna talk
about how FMRP deficits
can occur across many disorders, not only
in those that have the
whole mutation of fragile X
or even the upper end of the pre mutation
and the pre mutation is 55 to 200 repeats
but actually studies of brains, particular
by Fatemi et al, have
shown deficits of FMRP
in the brains of individuals with autism,
severe depression and bipolar disorder
and most dramatically in schizophrenia
and in fact the age of
onset in schizophrenia in IQ
in a population in Eastern
Europe in those papers there
correlate with the level of FMRP.
So the lower the level of
FMRP, and these are individuals
without a fragile X
mutation, the lower the level
of FMRP, the earlier the
onset of schizophrenia
and the lower the IQ.
Even tuberous sclerosis
neurons have been shown
to have deficits of
FMRP within the neuron.
Hypoxia at birth lowers FMRP
and even early life seizures
can significantly lower FMRP.
So seizures actually pull
FMRP away from the synapse
and FMRP is a protein
that regulates translation
of messages right at the
synapse and that relates
to environmental stimuli.
So it kinda turns on
and regulates messages
right at the synapse
that are really important
for synaptic plasticity.
And when you have repetitive seizures,
FMRP goes away from the synapse
and towards the cell body.
And maybe that's part of the reason why
there can be cognitive
deficits for individuals
with recurrent seizures.
But this just shows some
of the brain studies
in individuals with
bipolar disorder there,
depression and schizophrenia compared
to control brains, and none
of these have a mutation
in the FMR1 gene, the fragile X gene.
And early life seizures
pull these dots here,
are FMRP among the dendritic spines and
with early life seizures,
FMRP, which is this green
fluorescent, it goes away from the synapse
and to the cell body.
So when you dysregulate
FMRP from the synapse,
you're gonna have some cognitive deficits.
So FMRP not only controls translation
but it also is a messenger RNA carrier.
It's one of these proteins that does
just about everything.
It even controls epigenetic regulation
and I'll show you that in a moment,
or at least one of the
proteins, Brd4, important
for epigenetic changes in the DNA.
It can enhance the release
of neurotransmitters
presynaptically much more
rapidly so that the synapse
gets flooded with the neurotransmitters
so that individuals have,
when there's an absence
of FMRP, the synapse gets flooded
and they can't detect subtle
changes in the environment
that are important for learning.
It down regulates, when FMRP
is absent, the GABA receptors
are down regulated and then it
up regulates mGluR5 pathways.
So it has a lot of
effects and I think we're
just beginning to see some of the effects.
So it's a big mother controller protein
that when you mess with
FMRP, you get a lot
of effects in many different pathways
and we're learning more about it.
It actually up regulates
the insulin receptor
and I'll get more into that.
But this is the effects
on the Brd4 protein,
which is really important
for epigenetic regulation.
And so FMRP usually inhibits translation
but sometimes it stimulates translation.
And so when it's absent,
there's an up regulation
of proteins including Brd4 which produces
a lot more changes in transcription
because of the epigenetic regulation.
And then that in turn
influences what happens
at the synapse.
So this interaction, epigenetic
mechanisms with genetic
and environmental influences
is a very complex interaction
that can cause some
commonalities across disorders
and there's a lot of evidence
for epigenetic dysregulation
in individuals with autism, even in some
of the twin studies, monozygotic twins,
some of the methylation
studies that we've done
at UC Davis in Flora
Tussone's laboratory shows
dramatic methylation
changes in individuals
with idiopathic autism.
And whether that's related
to environmental toxins
or other factors in the
environment, we don't know.
I just wanna show you just a partial list
of some of the genes that are controlled
by FMRP, and this circle
are genes associated
with autism spectrum disorders.
These are all regulated by FMRP.
And these are the genes
associated with schizophrenia
or mood disorders.
So in about 10% of
individuals with fragile X,
they can be on the psychotic spectrum.
We've even seen psychosis
in some individuals
with the pre mutation, particularly those
that smoke a lot of
marijuana, which can push you
towards the psychotic spectrum.
And so we're very interested
in the interaction
in those with a fragile X
mutation with psychosis.
But you can also see
psychosis, I've seen many aging
ASD patients that have
developed psychotic thinking
over time too that's not associated
with smoking a lot of marijuana.
But there may be other
environmental toxins
that can enhance that.
So again as I mentioned,
many of the proteins
or the messages that
FMRP regulates, it binds
to actually almost over
3,000 mRNA targets.
Many of these genes again are associated
with fragile X or other
disorders, Angelman,
Prader-Willi, Rett
syndrome, actually MECP2
controls FMRP expression.
But FMRP controls the
cannabinoid system also.
So there's dysregulation
in the cannabinoid system.
I just wanna show you this complex slide
just to point out about the mTOR pathway.
Here's tuberous sclerosis
and this MET ERC pathway.
And those with P10 mutations
can have big heads.
This is neurofibromatosis
and these are all related
to this mTOR pathway and
this is gonna be important
when I also talk about metformin a minute.
So again, just to point out
how common the fragile X
mutations are, basically
about one in 200 females
in this area, I just
came back from Columbia
in South America and
there are huge pockets
of fragile X in different villages there.
In one village, one in 50 individuals has
a full mutation and more
have the pre mutation.
And we found some other villages where
there's just pockets of
fragile X I think related
to a founder effect.
And many pre mutation disorders there.
And so the pre mutation
disorders, it's the most
common cause of early ovarian failure,
the most common genetic cause
of early ovarian failure.
FXTAS is the fragile X
associated tremor ataxia syndrome
and it usually begins in the 50s or 60s
and affecting about 45 to 50% of the males
and about 16% of the females.
We've also identified
the fragile X associated
neuropsychiatric disorders or FXAND
because depression,
anxiety, ADHD, obsessive
compulsive disorder, chronic
fatigue, chronic pain
and fibromyalgia are definitely associated
with the pre mutation.
So the pre mutation is common
in the general population
whereas the full mutation
of fragile X is not
and the difference between
the two is the level
of messenger RNA.
So pre mutation carriers,
which are quite common
in the general population,
have dramatic elevation
in the messenger RNA,
as you can see there.
In the full mutation, the
whole gene gets methylated
so it shuts off message
unless you're a girl
and you have another normal X chromosome.
But it's the lack of the
message in the protein
that causes fragile X syndrome.
And again we have a subgroup of fragile X
that has a Prader-Willi like phenotype
with obesity and hyperphagia.
And these are the individuals
that I started treating first
with metformin 'cause it
is a treatment for obesity
and hyperphagia and it
helps them lose weight.
But then we found some
significant improvements
in language and conversational speech.
And that's why we're carrying
out a control trial now.
But hand flapping, hand
biting, poor eye contact
even those that don't
have a diagnosis of autism
and about 60% also meet
criteria for autism.
Some of 'em that don't have
autism and are very social
can still have poor eye
contact and hand flapping
and so some autistic features.
So the GABA deficit causes
a lack of habituation.
So here we look at sweat
response to repetitive stimuli
and usually whether it's a loud noise
or a visual stimulus, you
habituate in your sweat response
to repetitive stimuli.
But fragile X don't
because they don't have
a good GABA system.
They don't have a good inhibitory system.
And so they get activated
with repetitive stimuli.
So if you yell at them or try to spank 'em
or whatever, you often
will get into trouble
with significant aggression.
So you really have to
go into a calming mode
as this guy is telling me non verbally
that I'm taking too many pictures of him.
And so this is one of
the reasons why there's
significant aggressive outbursts.
They just get overwhelmed in
over stimulating situations.
And of course they have macro orchidism
which begins at about
eight or nine years of age
and these top lines
represent about 180 patients
we published many years ago,
and these are the normals
in terms of testicular volume here.
But they usually have
double jointed thumbs,
hyper extensibility
and this boy has a very
subtle strabismus, but
it led to amblyopia.
And biting on your shirt and biting things
are quite common.
So just getting into some
of the targeted treatments
as we talked about when FMRP
is usually the inhibitor
of this mGluR5 pathway.
And when it's not there,
there's up regulation
of many proteins including the proteins
that internalize the AMPAR receptors
and that's why you get long and immature
and weak dendritic spines.
So people thought, oh gosh, you just use
an mGluR5 antagonist and
you could cure this disorder
and that's what started the
targeted treatment field.
And we tried many mGluR5
antagonist, down regulating
this MET ERC pathway and in turn
maybe the mTOR pathway.
But none of them really worked,
particular in adolescents
and adults.
Tried many other things.
I'll touch on minocycline,
ganaxolone, allopregnanolone
is a neuro steroid, or
baclofen, a GABA agonist.
Even lithium will down
regulate this pathway
but it doesn't cure fragile X.
So now it's thought that
the earlier you start
a targeted treatment, you
will build a better brain
on which you can apply learning.
And so if you give an mGluR5 antagonist
in adulthood, which we have in many cases,
sometimes they do better
but the overall study
didn't show improvement.
So now NIH through
NeuroNEXT funded an AFQ056,
it's an mGluR5 antagonist made by Novartis
in a control trial, but on top of that,
at the end of the study
they can go on open label.
But on top of this
controlled trial of AFQ056
we added Parent Implemented
Language Intervention,
also called PILI, which
is done through Skype
by a speech and language pathologist
right into the patient's home.
And basically what it's doing
is it's teaching parents
how to stimulate language
at home, how to talk
about the things that
the kid's interested in,
how to promote language,
how to scaffold language.
I mean many of you know
about Hannon techniques
and other techniques.
Well it combines all of this
and it's very effective alone
for improving language
in kids with fragile X
between the ages of three and six.
And we've been able to demonstrate that.
And now we're analyzing the data,
well actually we're not
finished with the study yet.
We are not analyzing the data yet.
We have until May to do the enrollment.
It's at 14 different sites in the US
and hopefully will show some good results.
We've had some kids, I don't
know, it's a double blind
control trial so I don't
know what they're on.
But many have improved.
And so we're excited to look at the data
and to analyze the data soon.
It's led by Liz Berry
Kravitz, who's a really
great neurologist at Rush
University in Chicago.
And then we're all helping
her with this study,
and MIND is one of the sites.
So we did a minocycline
study a few years ago now.
And minocycline can down
regulate matrix metaloprotein
ACE9 or MMP9, which is up regulated
without the fragile X protein around
and that interferes
with synaptic plasticity
so you can bring it down to normal.
It actually improves
cognition and behavior
in the fragile X mice.
And we did a controlled
trial a few years ago
and we did show efficacy.
In blue on the CGII here, you can see
that it was somewhat better.
Of course there was a big placebo effect,
but we do get a significant effect.
It wasn't dramatic, but
we had a number of kids
that did very well on minocycline.
And most importantly, we
developed an event-related
potential, so this is
an EEG hat that's put on
that can look at habituation here,
looking at habituation with placebo
and with the minocycline.
And we brought back and
improved habituation.
Also looking at some of the amplitudes
which changed for the better.
But habituation improved dramatically
with minocycline.
So we've been using that
habituation paradigm
in many of our outcome measures along
with some new expressive language sampling
that Len Abbeduto, who's the director
at the MIND Institute, has developed.
Now in those with autism,
there is in the brain
a deficit of serotonin
production, particularly
in kids five or six
years of age and younger
compared to non autistic children.
This is a very old study by Chigani.
But then there was some metabolic studies
that demonstrated a paper by Boccoto et al
found abnormal expression
in the tryptophan metabolism
pathway in individuals with autism.
So here's tryptophan
and it gets metabolized
up to serotonin in the brain.
But all of these enzymes marked in blue
are all dramatically
down regulated compared
in individuals with autism
compared to controls.
So that was another factor that suggested
that the synthesis of
serotonin in the brain
is deficient in individuals with autism.
Now around that time, I also showed that
in a retrospective study,
that those young children
with fragile X syndrome,
when they were treated
with sertraline or Zoloft,
that their trajectory
of language development was much better
when I didn't treat them with sertraline.
Now the reason I was
treating them is because
anxiety kinda begins by
the second year of life.
And the anxiety can be
very severe in individuals
with fragile X syndrome.
And it seems to worsen
social interactions.
And here when I treated
them with sertraline,
I saw an improvement in language.
I didn't expect that.
I was just treating the anxiety.
And maybe if they were less anxious,
that's why they talked more.
But that's one of the reasons
why we did a control trial
and this has been published now in Journal
of Developmental and
Behavioral Pediatrics.
But it was a randomized controlled study.
And what we saw was that on the Mullen,
here's the reference here in the Journal
of Developmental and
Behavioral Pediatrics,
these are months improved
on those on sertraline
versus placebo, and we saw significance
in many of the sub tests on the Mullen.
Not all, I expected to see the best effect
in language but about
60% of those in the study
had autism and a post
hoc analysis in looking
at just those who had autism,
that they were the ones
that had a significant
improvement in expressive language
raw scores on this study.
So I thought, wow, well maybe
we should be using sertraline
in those individuals that have autism
without fragile X syndrome.
And we got funded to do a
low-dose sertraline study,
2 mg to 5 mg in kids
two to six years of age
with autism.
The vast majority were idiopathic.
We had a couple that had
a known point mutation
but without fragile X syndrome.
And we used very similar outcome measures
including the Mullens
and it was a randomized
control trial.
Here's the consort diagram.
And what we found is that
looking at the CGI-I,
this is sertraline in red, we had many
that actually really
did well on sertraline
and some looked like they even pulled out
of their autism.
But the overall
significance was not there.
So there's clearly just a subtype of those
with idiopathic autism
that seems to improve
with sertraline.
And we didn't see improvement
in any of the Mullen measures.
This is kinda broken up.
But a lot of this was in the negative
and those that were in the positive
were not dramatic.
So most, there weren't
any significant findings
on any of the Mullen sub tests.
That hasn't been published yet
but it is under revision
now also to General
Developmental and Behavioral Pediatrics.
So we hope to finish that
in the next few weeks.
So why did sertraline
work better in fragile X
than in idiopathic autism?
Well anxiety is a much
more significant problem
in individuals with
fragile X syndrome compared
to idiopathic autism, even
though anxiety can be a problem.
But in fragile X syndrome,
it's a major driver
of the severity of the
ASD because anxiety leads
to social isolation in individuals
with fragile X syndrome.
And the level of the anxiety correlated
with the level of the severity of autism
in children with fragile X syndrome.
And this very nice study
came out just recently
in Journal of Developmental Disorder
where they're looking at either pictures
of faces, they're also
looking at face processing,
where you look on a face.
And you remember that those with autism
and also with fragile
X syndrome don't look
at the eyes.
They look at the nose and at the mouth.
But there are social pictures
and then abstract pictures
here and compared to typical controls,
those with autism were less interested
in the social pictures.
Those with fragile X were more interested
And in the face processing,
there were differences,
I can't see this so well,
but the blue is fragile X
and the green is autism.
And this is where they look on the face
and how much time they
spend looking at the face.
But there are significant differences.
And in fragile X, there's
a lot less fixation
on the eyes.
Supposedly that's
overwhelming to the amygdala
compared to those with autism.
The interesting thing
is that in fragile X,
those with more anxiety
had less eye contact
but they were more interested
in the social scenes
and almost as if they were hypervigilant
to the social scenes.
So that was very interesting, that those
with fragile X with more
anxiety, were even more
interested in the social
scenes even though
they might have had a diagnosis of autism.
And that's very different for those
with idiopathic autism.
So let me get on to metformin.
It's a type two diabetes medication.
It's known to help with
overeating and obesity
and it's mainly used for
elevated hemoglobin A1Cs
in emerging and present type two diabetes.
But in the drosophila fragile X model
they found that in fragile X syndrome,
there was elevated insulin signaling
and that was brought down
to normal with metformin.
And the PI3K, Akt and mTOR
pathway was all down regulated
with metformin, and it
improved the circadian rhythm
deficits and the memory problems
in the fragile X drosophila model.
And it also rescued
the fragile X phenotype
in the fragile X mouse model,
the knockout mouse model.
So at this time, when I
was reading these papers
in 2017, I thought well
gosh, I should be using
more metformin in individuals
with fragile X syndrome,
particularly those that are fat or have
the Prader-Willi
phenotype and hyperphagia.
And indeed they all lost weight.
They improved their weight.
But the parents told me,
gosh, we're not so concerned
about the weight.
We really like the fact
that they could talk more
and I could finally carry out
a conversation with my son.
And so I thought, wow,
maybe there are cognitive
and language benefits.
And so I read a lot more about metformin.
Basically when you're on
metformin, it up regulates
AMPK and this inhibits this mTOR pathway.
But it also has a lot of other effects,
not only lowering the excess
protein that's produced,
but it has effects on
the autophagi, effects
on inflammation and a
lot of positive effects.
It has protection because
it lowers mTOR pathway,
it protects you against breast cancer,
cervical cancer, uterine
cancer, ovarian cancer
and not just female cancers
but many male cancers.
So I thought wow, this
is a really great drug.
So I decided I was gonna
go on metformin. (laughing)
I wanna be protected against these cancers
and live longer with
better cognitive abilities,
to spend time playing
with my grandchildren.
And the main side effect is diarrhea
but I didn't have any diarrhea.
And most patients don't have diarrhea.
But you increase the dose slowly
and we're doing a controlled
trial, ages six to 25
that the FDA approved and gave us an IND.
It's a randomized double
blind crossover study,
very easy study only lasting four months
with just a visit at baseline,
a visit at two months
and a visit at four months.
So if you have any fragile X patients,
send them to us because
this and many other trials
we have going.
And we're using the best of
the outcome measures we know.
The NIH toolbox that
David Hessel has organized
to be more valid for those
with intellectual disability,
behavioral measures, the
event-related potentials,
eye tracking with the Tobii tracker.
We have molecular biomarkers, MMP9
and a lot of other downstream proteins
on the mTOR pathway.
And so I think I'm seeing good effects
but I'm blinded.
We were funded by the Azrieli Foundation
to also do it in two centers in Canada,
Sebastian Jacquemont Center in Montreal
and Francois Boldec Center
in Edmonton in Canada.
So they were just with us this week.
So it's just a pleasure to
work with the Canadian teams.
So then I had a mom of
this two-year-old child
who's a pediatrician
at University of Utah.
And she's a developmental
and behavioral pediatrician.
She says after I presented
some of the metformin data
at a fragile X conference, she says I want
my two-year-old son on metformin.
And so I said well you
know, it's not approved
for two-year-olds.
And she said, I don't care.
I want it in my son.
And so we talked about using it clinically
and talking about a safe
dose, maybe just beginning
at 50 mg once and then twice a day
and sneaking up to a couple
of hundred milligrams
over the next year or so.
And she found some amazing effects.
He was stacking two blocks and then after
a couple weeks on metformin
he was stacking 11 blocks,
and she put that on her Facebook.
And then the next day
I had a slew of emails
from other mothers with two-year-old kids.
And actually we've had
a group of, actually
this is nine kids here and we're seeing
some improvements in behavior.
We looked at the developmental
testing on the Mullen
and compared it to the
developmental results
of those with fragile
X syndrome not treated
with metformin and it looked
like it boosted development
about twice of what you
would expect in fragile X.
So we think it has some good effects.
It's not a cure all.
I just wanna point out that
usually there's IQ decline
in fragile X over the
years and it's because
they don't keep up with
abstract reasoning.
So even though they don't lose skills,
their IQ over time will plateau faster
than the general population.
We have this kid who had
the Prader Willi phenotype.
We put him on Metformin.
He went back to the normal percentiles
but he was on metformin two years
before he went into
puberty and then I saw him
when he was Tanner stage three
and his testicles were normal sized.
For those of you who know
about a testicle increase
in fragile X, it really increases to
two to three times normal.
So I thought well gosh,
at least at the end
of my career I'm curing
the macro orchidism
in fragile X.
It's not a lot to be said for that
but I'd like to cure language.
But then we've had a couple of adults here
who have really boosted their
IQ after a year on metformin.
So we don't have all the
results of the controlled trial
on metformin, but we're
very hopeful it'll have
some significant language benefits
and maybe some cognitive benefits.
So I just wanna talk about
some other new treatments
for fragile X and autism.
The IGF1 analog, which is trofinetide,
it has been beneficial in fragile X
in a previous study that we did,
and it looks like it's very
beneficial in Rett syndrome.
We maybe even starting
an IGF1 analog study
in Rett syndrome at the MIND Institute
in the near future.
And there's gaboxadol that I talked about.
We're re enrolling 13 to 22
year-olds with fragile X.
It's a controlled trial.
Cannabidiol or CBD, different from THC
or a tetrahydrocannabinol,
will likely be helpful
from anecdotal information that I have
from many families with
autism and fragile X syndrome
for the anxiety and the
tantrums and aggression
that can occur.
And they get it from the marijuana stores
but it synthesizes the CBD.
So it's pure, it doesn't
have any THC in it
and the blood is negative for THC.
So the FDA really likes this.
And it's an ointment that
you rub on the shoulders
and use it twice a day.
So we're in the midst of
that controlled trial now
and they'll be enrolling this spring.
And hopefully we'll have the results
in the very near future,
we hope by next year.
They have done studies in Australia
and I'll show you that data.
These are open label studies in Australia.
Let me just, wait a second.
I don't need to talk about epidiolex.
But here's the zynerba
CBD studies in Australia
where each of these behavioral problems
from behavioral checklists
had significant benefit.
But of course an open label
study is very different
from a controlled trial.
So I'm not sure what we'll be seeing
with the controlled trial, but
I think it'll have benefit.
I just wanna mention about bumetanide.
That's been going on in a
study in Europe for autism.
Bumetanide is a very old
diuretic and it is impacting
the GABA system early on.
It's a diuretic and it can even be given
to one and two-year-olds.
And I haven't had much experience.
I've used it clinically.
We don't have a controlled trial going now
but I think the people from France
who started Lemonet and Benare and others
who started the Bumetanide
trial for autism in Europe
want to get more studies going.
They have a special liquid
preparation of bumetanide
but it does come in one
and two-milligram tablets.
And I use it on a five-year-old,
very severely autistic kid
from actually Korea who was visiting me
and were just desperate.
And I got an email a month later, this is
an amazing drug and my kid is talking.
So maybe we should use it more.
So think about bumetanide.
You have to look for calcium,
I'm sorry potassium deficiency
that sometimes can happen
with using a diuretic.
So sometimes you have to
supplement the potassium levels
but anecdotally it seems to be quite good
and there's control data
from the European studies
that have been published,
at least two papers on this.
So it's definitely something
we need to look at.
Epidiolex, I'm not gonna get into.
You can get CBD Gummies
that are 25 milligrams
per gummy on the internet.
And when you go to the
marijuana stores though,
they have all kinds of different solutions
of CBD to THC 20 to one
and it's really hard
to sort out how many
milligrams are in some
of the (mumbles) preparations.
But I think many of these
pure CBD preparations
are coming out.
And I'm not so sure you
need to include THC.
That seems to be the
anecdotal information around
that CBD won't work unless you have THC.
But the data from
Zynerba on the open label
in Australia shows that that's
not necessarily the case.
So I'd be happy to talk to anybody.
And oxytocin nasal spray twice a day
and ASD, those with the lowest
pre treatment oxytocin levels
benefited the most on the
social reciprocity scale
in autism.
So I think there will be
more use of the oxytocin
nasal spray, but I'm
not sure you can get it
by prescription yet,
and I haven't used it.
I also like yoga and
mindfulness meditation.
That really improves your GABA inhibition.
This is a high-functioning fragile X guy
who does yoga every day and he says
that his life centers around it.
And then also when we talk
about targeted treatments,
it's really important to think
about educational programs.
David Hessel has some data
on CogMed intervention
for individuals with fragile X.
Headsprout programs for
reading, AT devices,
particularly for those
that are non verbal,
iPad applications.
And this PILI intervention
of Parent Implemented
Language Intervention or even Sally Rogers
Early Start Denver model
of course is great,
and there's a paper out
a couple of months ago
showing it's great in individuals
with fragile X syndrome too, not just
in individuals with autism.
So many great educational
and behavioral problems.
So my time is up and I gotta stop.
But I wanna thank many of the people
that we collaborate with not only
at the MIND Institute, but we have a lot
of international
collaborations in Indonesia,
Philippines where I'm going
tonight and Australia,
Canada, and we do just a
lot of international work
and thank you very much.
(audience applauding)